Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192.
David P Here is my favorite thing and
honestly, it's not my favorite thing.
Here's someone who called in with some kind of
a message to me, but the show is just cranked
in the background so you can't hear anything.
Speaker 4: Joe Biden Hi, this is in 2023. I
drive a you know, and I have earthquakes hurtling.
And I think that we at least and it's important. I
just want to come back on something exciting.
Speaker 1: She was I believe she's commenting
about Kanye. But like her,
her voice is quieter than the show is.
Speaker 4: But it is going to be something
like this before and we are going to have
a hard time. Oh, that. You've done that.
Speaker 1: Okay, I can't do it. What's funny
is I hear myself explaining the big fight,
the fundraiser. So unfortunately she also called
right during my fundraising pitch, which is crazy.
So let me just mention it one more time. Friday,
December 23rd. That's this Friday we're doing our
last membership special of the year. You can get a
discounted membership. You'll get the bonus show,
you'll get the commercial free audio for.
Speaker 2: All of it. Oh, the bonus show
where you want to make money. Yeah. Everybody
else who makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: But here's the kicker. In addition to
you getting a discounted membership, everyone who
signs up Friday with the coupon code is going to
see their first membership payment donated by us
out to an organization that gives cash to people
who need it. And it's going to be doubled, your
contribution will be doubled. So if you get a $6 a
month membership, the $6 gets donated and then it
is matched up to 12, up to the first $15,000. All
you need to do for now is get on my mailing list.
You can sign up at David Pakman dot com Friday.
You'll get an email telling you what to do.
It's going to be great. I hope it's really
successful. On today's bonus show. Speaking
of the bonus show. Argentina have won the
World Cup for the first time in 36 years. I
wore my jersey today. Yes, this will be the last
round for the jersey until the next World Cup.
Everybody relax. We will talk about it. We will
talk about the insanity also of the World Cup in
Qatar and we'll talk about the next World Cup. We
will also talk about an Ohio teacher who told the
principal that using the preferred pronouns of
students violates her religion. Oh, God, this is
happening now. And lastly, guns confiscated at
U.S. airports have hit record levels. And it's
not only Madison Cawthorn getting caught, it's
other people as well. All of those stories and
more on today's bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman
dot com get instant access. We will see you then